o fluxo trika catar
drica euipa pai é tamanha é a igreja que
esse campeonato você em nosso isso
comigo sabe coisa maravilhosa comigo
minha vida está de vento em poupa em
uvas e hoje está tudo bem não porque
aqui está tudo bem porque hoje eu tô
doente veja só o índice são muitos
estado entre a área vai ficar doente é
pai
não eles não entendeu a todo mundo adora
ficar doente é do gripado cana onde você
fica gripada é porque você não um
problema não fica só uma coisa só ele
tem que buscar você tudo por si a matrix
a sua matriz buga é como assim quando
você fica gripado não é só o seu nariz
eo sistema respiratório que busca você é
bonito fico febre você ver com ele cair
a garganta a garganta dói o único na
garganta dói é porque as pessoas não
sabia pra você e fala nossa ele está
doente
vou dar minhas condolências e embora a
pessoa tem que querer conversar com a
gente pra saber como é que a gente ficou
doente mas saber o que aconteceu sempre
com a gaveta do r8 para falar porque dói
esse rapaz na recta cabe destacar há
muito tempo do equipamento do empate
eita doença na região até ou não pareço
por área do povo na carona do carro do
povo de lisboa foi a pá na lista dos
países por onde o rei se ele começa às
9h começa a saída do em observar do povo
por aí
o dói né bicho a gente ficou doente no
mercado e o ruim é que dói pra [ __ ] né
bicho pior campanha do café do e book
o gasto nessa boca se vocês vão catar
neste vídeo aqui é cenográfica está
totalmente bugado ela sabe o que é pior
porque a pessoa ela fica boa
o ano tem [ __ ] nenhuma não tem nada pra
fazer
tem nada ta bolsão pronto prato do dia
que aparece amanhã eu vou pra fortaleza
no dia que aparece uma coisa para fazer
buba é desgraça e nós e edgar ficar
doente não tem falado muito também do
lado bom das coisas e quando cantado em
todo mundo faz tudo pela gente me fala a
verdade
não adianta você ganha vídeo pra mim não
porque eu sei que faz aí
mãe tô com fome como aceitar que o
biscoitinho eu ficar aqui
obrigado obrigado mãe o meu deus de fome
o filho do conselho mãe está aqui eu
estava tocando meu filho dom ligado em
mim que eu to assim meus olhos se todo
eu tô precisando assim de entretenimento
assim é tão chato manhã por favor do seu
filho ao reino que eu fique aqui em feio
enfim olha essa palavra todo momento
enfim começa a casa onde o silva para
lutar aqui na porta de casa por favor
uma coisa que seu filho está pedindo
pode ser amanhã o gotham book ela faz
mais um e não tem condição de trazer um
ano seu patrimônio
no vídeo de uma mãe pode você está recém
curada é que você ainda pode fingir
estado e às vezes você pode usar o
benefício de você ter ficado doente é
recentemente para poder se livrar das
coisa ruim felipe neto felipe neto vetá
que nota vermelha é essa aqui no seu
boletim e eu que prova mas a nota não
voltou se faça de desentendido filipe
neto essa nota aqui o três e meio e
março mas não faz sentido uma filipe
neto felipe neto eu já te falei que
quando não te digo a todos e no dou
minha cara
ventura venha cá que você vai aprender
ai ai ai
amém o mercado não é hoje adotado para a
mesma de caminha para a mesma palavra é
bom também que o mundo tá muito
atualizada a mãe não sabe das coisas que
aproveitá-la vasco quem não sabe e nem
me ajuda que lavar louça estavam aí
quando falam ainda não falou e o bom é
que quando a gente é filho na situação
de filho a gente consegue ludibriar a
mãe da gente bonita a doente a gente
fica mais miguel falabella quando a
gente está doente a equipe consegue
interpretar a gente consegue interpretar
o papel de samuel jackson não sabe
interpretar e me ajuda aqui vai a casa o
que mãe e ela vai colocar o seu filho
doente o trabalho escravo menino tá com
dor de cabeça tanto alejado mamãe mamãe
a minha cabeça mãe é que manda no meu
corpo de papel jornal chamado inscrição
está fazendo com que eu fizesse isso
comigo mãe que é o seu filho postado em
ferro aqui nesta cama você me pediu para
fazer trabalhos desse tipo mãe
derrotado no estádio mãe eu te peço pelo
amor que certa tendo me deixa aqui nesta
câmara jogando o meu ps3 e aquilo que me
faz ficar melhor mãe roma pode ser a
última vez que eu jogo neste vídeo game
mãe pode ser a última turnê
é realmente emocionante a história do
rapaz e agora quer saber de você quando
você está doente o que você acha bom o
que você acha que comenta aqui embaixo
é a primeira vez que estava disse já
clicou inscrever-se propina o vídeo em
com a galera queria pedir um negócio
aqui no fundo do meu coração eu tô
doente eu tô gravando um vídeo pra vocês
tô eu estou usando minhas últimas forças
pra falar parte da câmera com todas as
minhas últimas forças para transmitir
esta câmera e as palavras eu estou
transmitindo que podem ser menos últimas
palavras
então te peço do fundo do meu coração da
undime mt pode ser o tipo light que você
vai ouvir o meu carro quando imagina
você fechando esse vídeo sem falar que
nesse vídeo jacinto apontada no estado
obrigado a assistir se viu até aqui
galera
você já sabe né que ele twitter tá aqui
na descrição do vídeo você me seguir
pela está a grana tem o facebook você
não vai perder nenhum vídeo por que
sempre eu boto lá no twitter botas da
mesma tribo então valeu valeu